which character do you relate most to  two characters leap to mind one is more  than the other the loveliest human being  we all wrote for and this was a giant  collaboration yeah was Edith and and mud  made me laugh in places and my body I  didn't even know existed yeah I love  that I look I would have never guessed  that and it's two women that's amazing  the characters you related to we're an  even men so you just like to write  better characters for women I like you  already  I find I like women yeah you kind of  like you invited all of us your bed  obviously like and that was a beginning  yeah I know you need any dinner I like  it I like it it's a cheap date I will  not stop talking until you subscribe to  my youtube channel that's right and I  could talk a lot seriously not gonna  stop yep still here not going anywhere I  see you don't walk away from this